Gears of War for is scheduled to release
sometime this year and I'm sure you
gears fans out there have plenty of
questions what's the plot about who are
we fighting and who are we actually
controlling well thanks to Game Informer
magazine's latest cover we can at least
answer that last question the gears of
war forecast has been revealed and at
least one character has very strong ties
to the previous games in the center of
the cover is JD phoenix son of marcus
fenix the lead cog soldier from previous
gears of war games he's voiced by Liam
McIntyre who played Spartacus on the
Stars series of the same name to his
right is Kate Diaz a survivalist raised
outside the protective walls of Sarah's
cities she's voiced by laura bailey who
you've probably heard as street fighters
chun-li and finally there's X cog
soldier Delmont Walker voiced by Eugene
bird he can be heard as boomer and
battlefield hardline Gears of War for
doesn't have a set release date yet but
if you played gears of war remastered
online before march first you're already
guaranteed access to the beta when we
hear more about that beta or the full
release you'll hear about it too and for
all the gears of war news you need
you're already in the right place
you